hey guys I'm Ryan right Sally's that mic
on yeah okay so today we're gonna do a
challenge Sally is here but I have to do
this one alone first try to watch this
without screaming or scaring okay and
there's rules you got to follow number
one do not speed up or skip you'll spoil
the whole test number two volume has to
be between 25 to 55 percent but louder
video bigger challenge some are blasted
watch it for the first time let me watch
it once or use your headphones that's
why I got these 5 remove distractions so
Sally is off to there she cannot see
what I'm about to watch but she can hear
me if I scream or not oh god I'm so
nervous now that's over a million views
I'm like holy [ __ ] I haven't read any
comments no comments alright here we go
one two three
yeah it's get close it's all the way up
the volume you're insane
yes I can pass this test without
screaming level one scary image Oh
again analyst level 2 scary images with
creepy music and slower feeding
you well I'm not a lot of get grossed
out I forget scary facts okay
a man in the 1890s dug up his daughter's
grave and cut off her heart thinking she
was a vampire sorry
oh that's disgusting level four
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] oh no video over okay Sally you're
up you're doing it get over here get
over here we get over here don't look I
can't do this sure you can no no one
question one question does it have dolls
I can't tell you that
No No please please cuz I'm like
actually really scared of dolls I can't
tell you that not like you have to
because I I don't recall seeing adult I
really don't wanna do this I'm the worst
I get scared of everything yeah I know
hello let me just grab my suddenly eat
fresh I can't put it on full volume oh
halfway the volume for you no that's a
lot no Sally do it copyright strike this
is only gonna be less than 15 minutes
alright Sally you ready hold it next to
my ears no yeah put it in no no no I
don't want quit being a [ __ ] I am a
[ __ ]
okay alright one two over here
you're losing I don't like these I've
seen that before
okay
oh no no
Oh No
earphones are so far for me I can't cuz
I okay that's actually pretty cool I
can't
scary packs I can deal with this I read
Twitter
I'm trying to go now
I've run scarier stuff on Twitter and
Tumblr
that's like something from the deep dark
web Lord Jesus
my seances shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up
oh don't stand over there Greg your
sister Ryan your steerage Oh Lord
[ __ ] oh you [ __ ] I thought my heart
stopped this is almost over how many
levels No
okay okay
you did it you fast congratulations half
of the work well you survived [ __ ] well
guys thanks for setting that our way ah
I just had an energy drink and now I
need to make me drink like calm down I
was [ __ ] hilarious if you guys are
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
salamander Sally's channel a lot of fun
[ __ ] on there and also you can check out
Sally's vlog that she recently posted
check it out I just saw it I really
liked it it features her speaking with
Howie Mandel actually so should check it
out it's very short but it's worth it
sure you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine and why not
let's do a shout out you know what I
want to shout out this guy deserves a
second shadow
Joey Fajardo he created the real rejects
banner for us he's a fan of the channel
thank you so much Joey Fajardo dude
Fajardo if I was homo for Fajardo I
would totally blow yo P no yo Joey you
sure